welcome to this video playing right here
against God won't grow master loosed em
off and this is a great quite bad score
what do I have here one out of eight
that's not good okay let's see what we
can do here in the in the Dutch show
yeah I got a series of holy good
opponents and that didn't score well
getting my rating down from the high
2400 to the low ones that's a weird kind
of yeah kind of stone wall but I'm going
to fix this issue with the with the
knight on c3 by playing this sequence I
think you can do that it loses a bit of
time but the night is just not good on a
six doesn't matter very much that he has
this move extra
they have a terrible scoring and through
stem off i just won once i remember that
game when i played this was on a live
stream an icc live stream so he tries to
somehow make use out of that okay i want
to play quickly in this game not spend
ages check okay one really 94 you want
to do that i don't believe in that one
bit I'm not going to spend time on
covering this pawn with this kind of
weak and poor information goalporn
hunting ok let's just see if I can get
some pressure on the clock here queen
bee three maybe it's got Quinn before
now let's start with that taking on d5
then should be should be at least okay
for white I can take b7 as well how does
he cover his stuff then e 7 and this
also d5 coming now that's good for white
it's just good for white I think the
ship f6 might be possible I thought d5 I
forgot that this is hanging actually d5
bishop a 1 d6 hmmm to be honest that
looks good from white but it's not
necessary of course I don't have to do
this kind of drastic measure can I do
something against this Queen I don't
think so i can when i'm going to play
that I feel like that it's right this
Bishop is hanging I'm threatening Bishop
c4 okay and also let's eat 7 which is
kind of dangerous e 7 and a 95 95 next
for Bishop c4 I can take with the bishop
oh you can take that with the bishop I
should have seen that how idiotic is
that come on I was playing too quickly
yeah that's not good
my a to Bishop is hanging out so just
awful yeah it's just really awful ah man
I'm such an idiot why did not take one
moment down and just win this game can I
go Queen d7 for the check their queen e6
and Queen f7 this kind of thing I should
have just taken one moment down can't
just kill him okay maybe I'm still okay
him takes then promotes this is a draw
at least check okay at least I'm getting
a drawer of this act but it was this is
really to to to the back for what I had
check check grah aah chak game drunk ah
wow that is a spoiled sean i think it
was really good yeah for once for once
and Bishop takes is also just great iam
but ok taking here and no d5 is right
Bishop takes and now why just flat-out
wins yeah I no surprise there I just
have to think for one moment e seven and
now not this bloody nightie fire but
just play in the right move order yeah
95 check here and now g5 and resigned
Sam that's it yeah threatening night of
74 mate and he has no moves he has no
more pookie seven Queen 88 it's just
completely completely and winning okay
can also take him it's funnier after
funny position you moves the Queen
somewhere I can take care for made yeah
and this is even that is good for wide
that's funny
but not this the check here first Jack
and Bishop age five and white still is
better okay okay cannot go g6 he cannot
take on e seven and all kinds of stuff
is hanging the queen is completely out
of the picture this is the best defense
according to stockfish no and white is
bad i am clear look at this what it's
definitely better still huh yeah okay
this is then I was too angry him but I
was lucky that he that he played this
after which it's a draw this is this is
winning for black not that I understand
why but it wins check why is this not
possible like in the game Queen to g4 ah
this is this is the point okay he's
covering g7 from there okay so then I'm
missing the tactic yeah on g7 yeah lucky
outcome that I that I got a draw of
course it was a complete win with many
many ways I simply think that that this
is not a good way to play mc5 check this
is just neglecting all kinds of opening
principles yeah moving multiple times
with the same piece and so on while you
have a weak central formation I don't
think that this is any good now white is
already clearly better in this position
the night on a six and everything is
weak this is this is simply not not good
yeah I should have punished it with with
this Queen d5 move okay it was
interesting though thanks for watching